could you do me a quick favor if you're
listening to this please hit the follow
or subscribe button it helps more than
you know and we invite subscribers in
every month to watch the show in person
my desire to be strong was because i
knew one day
i may have to kill my father
athlete artist actor terry crews
that's right i've always wanted to be a
superhero one of my earliest memories
was my father
knocking my mother out she'd be nursing
a black eye and i would just dance in
front of her and she just started
cracking up in the middle of all that
pain i saw the ability to make her laugh
pornography numbered my pain i had this
addiction for the longest time how did
it impact your marriage
she said i was different
i damaged my family i damaged my wife
you gotta own up to it you have to do
what's within your power to make things
right
one thing i that that changed for me
is i stopped competing with people and i
said
don't try to be the best
be the only
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of a ceo usa edition i hope
nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
terry i i always start these
conversations in a very similar way but
having read your new book tough
i feel like it's never been more
relevant to what i'm about to say
reading through your your new book
especially in the first chapter it
becomes so blatantly clear how
our early context shapes who we become
in many ways and
there's never been a more glaring
example of that
so
i feel like that has to be the place we
start can you tell me about that context
in which you were raised
wow uh first and foremost um i
was raised in um flint michigan and
i was born in 1968 and and i just want
to give some context in the fact that
flint michigan was the palo alto of the
united states what i mean by that is
general motors was the most successful
corporation in the world
and
you know there were opportunities there
were money there was homes and
people were doing very very well and the
city was growing and blossoming and my
father
was a foreman
at buick
um during this time he he was a poor kid
who moved up from edison georgia a town
of less than 300 people and moved and
went up north to find to work in the
factory and became a foreman and
my mother was a housewife
and she was raised born and raised in
flint
my mom had got pregnant with me before
they were married and they shortly soon
sooner after got married and
what was so wild about that is that
amongst all this
you know
kind of opportunity
my father was very very abusive and
you know one of my earliest memories
around you know the time i was about
four or five years old was my
father
knocking my mother out um
and
what was really crazy you know he was
alcoholic
um
and here here you have a man who came
from
he really never shared his past with me
i had to actually find out
a lot about his past later on in my
adult years
but i never really understood him
and he never really volunteered any
information
and then my mother however was very
religious
um she grew up in the church of god in
christ which was what you would call the
holiness movement and it was you know
the term was holy rollers and
you know she couldn't wear makeup she
could she wore her dresses down to her
ankles
we were not allowed to go to the movies
not allowed to
listen to secular music not allowed
to
play sports uh basically everything that
i ended up doing in my life i was not
allowed to do um and it was we were in
church probably six days out of a seven
day week so
it was unindated with religion um a lot
of guilt a lot of shame
a lot of um
you know
god's gonna get you
you know if you don't you know this is
the way they felt they needed to keep
you in line so there was a very toxic
mix in my household because here you
know my father was an alcoholic and my
mother is religious and so they always
went at each other because you weren't
allowed to do what my father was doing
and my mother was always challenging him
and yelling at him about it and he would
go off and
and i just wanted peace man
it was just violent you know i actually
went to bed until i was 14 years old
because it was not a peaceful night you
know i would wake up to screaming wake
up to glass breaking shouting my one
time i woke up my father was bleeding my
mother had stabbed him
and the police came and in that day it
was like
you know there was no such thing as
domestic violence just like there was no
such thing as alcoholism
you know it was just he can't handle his
liquor uh i was kind of saved by my high
school because it was it was a special
school
that allowed you to come because you had
certain talents and it was from
seventh grade all the way to my senior
year
and i had art ability
and one thing about being in this
religious household is that i had a
really vibrant imagination because we
couldn't do anything else so i would go
to school and people would tell me about
movies they saw and things that they
were listening to and all this stuff so
i would go home and draw it
so because i wanted to watch it so bad
and be there so bad
and so i would start drawing and i
remember you know one thing my mom did
let me do was comic books and so i would
copy the comic books and the heroes and
they had muscles and
i was like one day i'm gonna be like
that and um
but i also found out
which was so wild a little bit later
even in therapy was just that i found
that
a lot of my my desire to be strong
was because i knew one day
i may have to kill my father
because he was just that person
and it was intense man it i i guess it
was a very very intense
upbringing um
and i became this person who just wanted
to keep the peace
because it was
i just
anything to keep the peace i became what
you would call a pleaser like
mom what do you need to do i'll be a
good boy i promise i'll i'll sing in the
church i'll sing in the choir and then
my father will come home he's like what
you want another beer whatever you want
you know i'll just make sure you you
don't get angry you know
and
it was just about i was i was exhausted
you know and i remember just being that
tired
um and it was
it was a lot of work
because
i i lost all my
like who i was
um it was dependent on who was around
and i was all of a sudden be what they
wanted me to be
did you ever try and intervene when your
parents were having conflict did you
ever try and intervene at a young age
he was too big i mean it was one of
those things where i felt helpless
i felt
100 like i was so small
and you just look and i say my father
you know
even says that you know we call him big
terry he was always big terry and i was
little terry and this is how we referred
to each other all over the house and my
my older brother is my half brother
so he was smaller than me
and we were just i just always felt tiny
i remember just looking at his hands and
they were big giant calloused hands and
the way he'd walk around the house you
just hear boom boom boom you know
it was a drama you know it was it was
like man this man could rip me apart
and i had a desire to get strong
i knew i had to protect one day would
have to protect my mom protect my family
because i remember
the nightly news and they would always
tell you all the horror stories you know
so-and-so kills his whole family you
know
i was always look at the tv and i would
say you know
i think my father could do that
i mean this is not the thoughts
a seven-year-old should be having but i
remember thinking
i wonder if he got mad enough would he
how would he kill us all
you know
and
because the rage would just flip
and my father was two people it was um
he would be sober on his way to work
and then he would come home
and when that car pulled up
he was he would usually go to the bar
first
and he was a different person
he was sad
he was crying he was angry he would be
listening to old soul music on the
record player and this is one of my
memories i even put in a book was just
i remember looking at him
and i looked at my father and i was
i really felt sorry for him
i just remember he coming home he's
disheveled he's been drinking
and he the pocket protector was all
messed up shirt was all undone he used
to have short sleeve shirts with ty and
the tie was off and everything and he
just sitting there and he got a beer in
his hand
and he'd just be sitting there and he
just looks so sad and i just
i walked over to him
and i kissed him on the cheek
and he looked at me
like i had an eye in the middle of my
forehead
he looked at me with such
disdain
and
contempt
and i said i'll never do that again
it was like oh man
oh and i felt like
he looked at me like
it was the worst thing i could have ever
done
and i said okay that's it like
we are clear
you and i we're clear we know i know
never to cross that you know across that
line ever again
i'll never forgot that
i mean even talking about it now it just
it shook me to my core
because i expected love and oh man it
was my son
and it was
disdain um he didn't know he didn't know
how to do it
and so
that's what it was and my whole
young life
i knew i had to get out
because i didn't want to be a part of
this super hyper religious world
there were so many things i wanted to do
i had a lot of dreams i had a lot of
goals um and one thing what was crazy is
that my mother loved entertainment she
loved it we used to sit around and watch
the carol burnett show
together as a family every saturday
night
and
i remember watching her laugh like
looking at what made her laugh what was
gonna and she crack up at carol burnett
and i said one day
that's me like i'm gonna make her laugh
like that so i would do things around
the house
and i remember her she'd be nursing a
black eye
that my father gave her and she'd have
like some frozen peas on her face
and i was just dancing in front of her
and she just started cracking up
and uh
in the middle of all that pain i saw the
ability that i had
to make her laugh during all that and i
said this is a power
in the middle of this kind of pain
that she's just she's literally in tears
laughing
at her son you know and i said
okay this is how
i'm gonna get by this beginning the
pleaser just
make everything better this is going to
cool everything out right
and that was that was most of my
existence as a little boy growing up in
flint michigan that's the context did
you ever find out where
that pain you saw in your father
originated from i did i did
um and you know what's crazy i only
found this out
literally like a year ago
which is nuts
cause he would never answer me
there's so many things
i never ever
he never answered i would ask but they
uh no big deal you know
and i did a show with henry lewis gates
called finding your roots
and he went into my family's past
and i found out
that my grandfather
he abandoned his family
so he abandoned my father and my father
had an older brother younger sister
and my grandmother had been abandoned by
him now i knew my grandmother but again
you're talking about in black culture in
america
a lot of these things were just too
painful to talk about
no one ever you could ask but you'd get
a nod you'd get go play
don't worry about it
um and no one would talk
but he found out that my grandfather had
abandoned the family
and
he was basically had robbed
a liquor store
and was on a chain gang
in
georgia which is probably one of the
most brutal
uh punishments you could get at the time
in america at the time it's a chain gang
a chain gang is when they would make you
build a highway um they would take
prison populations
chain them together
and they would be the ones that would be
clearing out forests um
clearing out paths with
with um stakes and
shovels and and it would be backbreaking
work all day long in a hundred degree
heat and he did that
for about two years but this was the
strange this was where the pain comes
from
my uncle told me that they had to they
took the school bus
to school and they had to pass the train
gang
where his dad was
and where they knew their dad was
working
and this was so traumatic for them
because they didn't want people to find
out
they would visit him in jail but
it was
you know off and on and he would act
like he didn't want to see him
it was really really just painful and
he got out and he did a couple more
things and ended up in jail again
um
and finally he died of epileptic seizure
when my father was 17 years old
and you're talking about
never really
want my father never felt wanted
never felt he was his blood son but it
just
was any you know it was a pauper's grave
um there's a headstone that's cracked
right now so it's not even a headstone
it's kind of like a
just a block with his name on it edward
cruz
and it's broken in half and i plan on
putting a proper headstone on that
sometime this year
but it's
i started to understand
i started understanding that pain
and it drove my father to drink at a
young age
and you know
one thing that we do as men
is that we we
we tend to
to numb
numb ourselves
because you you know this is a part of
you feel like you're being tough you
feel like you're being strong like okay
i don't feel that pain you know i can't
show that pain i can't
and drinking is a big big way
of numbing your pain for me it was
pornography pornography numbed my pain
um
and like i never i still to this day
i've never been drunk i've never been
high i don't i don't do that but
pornography
was something that took me
out when did you make it into your life
pornography when was the first time man
i first discovered porn at about nine
ten years old
i was over my uncle's house and
he had a chest full of pornography um
and this is the thing you know it's
funny because
you know people have said well you know
yeah there's nothing wrong with
pornography you know
with adults and the whole thing but the
problem is is that you know you never
find it as an adult
i don't know anybody who found
pornography as an adult
uh you always find it as a child it's
everywhere
and it's funny because i've been told
hey man you know
just mind your business it's all good
you know
keep to yourself that's your issue but
porn never keeps itself to itself
um i get texts today
i get texts now
people
text to me it's something like us
fishing and they text you porn and text
you
hot girls in your area now you're like i
didn't ask for this
you know what i mean but you start to
realize
that they know what they're doing
they know they can get a hook and they
know if they can get it in you and they
know
if they can get into young and this was
the thing that attracted me to porn
is that you would i would open up the
magazines and they would have comics in
them
and the comics and different things they
would have subjects like goldilocks and
you know
and snow white and
all these story a jack and jill you know
and you start to realize wow this is
really like this is stuff i realized as
an adult
that this is um
this is this is wired
they're wired to get you young you know
what i mean and to stay in there because
they know it'll never go away you know
and that was what attracted me i was and
again i didn't even know what sex was
but man
all i knew
is when i opened that magazine and saw
those ladies in that magazine and how
beautiful they were
all my problems were gone like
it was numb
like i didn't know anything about
violence about
where i was it was just like it was i
could zone away
and every problem was disappear
and i had to have it
like
when things got stressful whenever i'll
never forget because again and here's
another thing because you're going to
resist just household so you know you're
doing wrong you know it was like oh
that's bad you know
but this was also time when pornography
was in the grocery store
and it wasn't seen as something it was
just kind of like there we go and i
remember telling my mom i'm gonna go in
the store and get some milk
and i remember just
grabbing one of those magazines and i
couldn't stop until she bumped she's
like hey what are you doing
and i would just she would take me out
of this
numbing
experience i was having and i'm standing
there in the store and i told her i
would get some milk and there i was
she's like i was waiting for you for a
half hour what are you doing
but i was stuck
and that's that kind of power
that
was on me like
and i i had this addiction
for the longest time how long oh my
all the way up until 2010
right from my whole life from 19 from
literally
from the time i was about 10
to
all the way up
to about 12 years ago
and when you say addiction a lot of
people might not know what that means a
lot of people might think that means
watching porn from now now and then or
looking at a magazine now and then what
did what did that mean in reality what
was the if you've got an example of how
bad it got for you yes um first of all
it was
it was
i got a day off from
the set
so
i'm usually on location
and
i could watch porn
from
[Music]
uh probably 10 o'clock after my workout
10 a.m
to 11 p.m at night
10 a.m to 11 p.m at night it wouldn't
stop
and i couldn't stop
and i'll go from one to the next
to the next
to the next and it was
and and the fact that i knew that no i
was in a different place and no one
would know me and no one cared
i could indulge and just
it was a it was what you would call a
splurge like it just couldn't stop i
couldn't when day turns into night
and you're still watching
i knew i had a problem
i knew i had a problem and
and when you tell yourself you not that
like i'm not gonna do this anymore
and then you go right back
because what was happening i found
is
you know with the porn it was like i
need i would say okay i'm done with that
whatever and i would feel guilty
but with guilt comes shame
and with the shame
shame says and shame doesn't say you
does you've done something bad
shame says you are bad
like you this is who you are you're just
bad
so what you would do is do a bunch of
good things
and you would just work hard and
i go good for like three four days and
then you need a reward
and what is that reward because you did
so good
it's porn
and so you go back in
and the cycle starts all over again
and i found it would just keep going on
and on and on how did it impact your
marriage because you got married in 1989
listen
it
first of all i got married
in
1989
to the most beautiful woman on earth and
rebecca
i met her she's from gary indiana we met
in college i actually met in church
which was wow because i vowed i wasn't
going to be religious but what was wild
is that i couldn't get away from the
things i felt and the things i was used
to
um
and so i went to church and met her and
she was on the piano and she was the the
church leader the worship leader
and she had a child just like my mom had
a child
and uh it was a little girl
and she was only six months old and we
got married when she was two
and this was the thing
i thought that once i got married
the porn would go away i said man i got
a real woman now
oh i don't have to tell her about
anything we just gonna
you know it was a phase i'm gonna be out
of it it's gonna be great
and then the first argument
the first
well you feel like it no i don't feel
like it tonight
okay i'll be right back
oh the first sexual conflict
i'm going out to get pornography
um
and
i thought it would free i thought it was
going to be my answer to what it was but
i realized
it didn't i decided that was gonna be my
secret and then you develop a thing
where you think if you're in secret
everybody's in secret
like
i'm sure you know this is just the way
everybody is you know
it wasn't until i got into therapy that
i realized i said no no
not everybody's like that terry i was
like wait wait what what do you mean
like you don't do that you know
it was a surprise to me um
but it was no different than
any other
thing that would numb you be it alcohol
be drugs
and this is the thing too um
[Music]
you know what what i learned what i
thought was awesome was the 12-step
program
12 steps
was really established by alcoholics
anonymous but it works
for basically a lot of different
addictions i mean
and the
you know starting with the serenity
prayer which is you know
god helped me accept the things
that i cannot change and the courage to
change the things i can
and the wisdom to know the difference
well the thing was that what i got
backward in my whole life
was that i was trying to change things i
couldn't change
at all
and the things that i could
i felt i was powerless
so if you have those things backwards
it's not wisdom
you know
and
what was so
unbelievable to me i i just remember
because the the wake-up call of all
wake-up calls was what we call d-day
around our house
and it was february 2010
and my wife
uh was basically you know over the years
she was always suspicious
but what had happened is 10 years
earlier
basically in 2000
i had went to a massage parlor and got a
hand job and cheated on her
and man
i vowed vowed
that i would never tell a soul like
i was so hurt i couldn't believe i did
that like you know you think i would no
i could only do this and that you know
it's gonna stop here
but
it just fueled the walk for more
and i actually crossed the line
and when i crossed that line i couldn't
believe i did that and i knew
i said i'm gonna go to my grave with
this
i said no one's ever going to know
and
that's just the way it's going to be
well
years go by like
and but my wife was always suspicious
like you know
what what's up with you terry and i'm
like i'm good i'm good and i remember
starting arguments so she would stop
talking
because what happens is one lie
turns into two turns into a hundred
and over ten years
you forget you start to forget which lie
you told you know things start to
conflate and what makes you like mixing
up and and the pornography never stopped
it would it would be at a low but i you
know i go like a month and be like oh
wow i'm good and then
and
man
it all culminated i'll never forget
february 2010
she was like
what is it
i don't know about you terry crews
there's something i don't know
i can't
man
it broke me
because we were on the phone literally i
was in new york she was in california
and i was working on a project and now
this is another thing i want to say i
was very successful
very successful you talking rich
making money famous
popular
everybody loved terry crews it was like
wow you know mr white chicks mr this
this didn't you know it was phenomenal
money was rolling in we were doing well
and i'm like what she has to complain
about you know it's a good life you know
and the question i would ask her and i
would literally ask myself was like why
doesn't she believe me
when the question i should have been
asking is why am i lying
it's two different it's the context the
same
two different views
you know and i had blamed her for not
believing me that's
that's how deep it goes and i'm gonna
tell you
success is the warmest place to hide
because no one's going to call you on
your [ __ ]
nobody's going to say hey maybe you
should
you get a lot of psychopaths you get a
lot of people telling me you're telling
you you're right you're right i had tons
of people like man you good
in comparison to everybody else oh my
god you never hit your wife you never
you you bring the money home you do all
this stuff
but
but i was not
real i was a lie
i was living a lot
and when i told my wife
i heard this gasp on the other end
[Music]
and i was like oh boy
i think it's over and she said
you know i'm done
she's like i don't know who you are
i have no idea because see to me it
happened ten years ago
but to her it happened today
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast as the seasons
have begun to change so has my diet and
um
right now i'm just gonna be completely
honest with you i'm starting to think a
lot about
slimming down a little bit because over
the last couple of probably the last
four or five months my diet has been
pretty bad
and it started to show a little bit
really over the last two months i go to
the gym about 80 of the time so i track
it with 10 of my friends in a whatsapp
group and this tracker online that we
all use together we call it fitness
blockchain and i'm currently at 81
percent um so 81 of the days i've done a
workout in the last 150 days right so
i'm going to the gym about six times a
week
that's been a little bit impacted by the
derivatio live tour but i'm trying to
stick to it
and so one of the things i'm doing now
to reduce my calorie intake and trying
to get back to being nutritionally
complete and all i eat is i'm having the
heel protein shake thank you hill for
making a product that i actually like
the salted caramel is my favorite i've
got the banana one here which is the one
my girlfriend likes but for me salted
caramel is
the one what did you tell her
i told her
that
i went to a massage parlor
in vancouver
and i got a hand job
and i said
it happened i told her i was like 10
years ago it was a long time ago
this is the one thing you don't know
why did you tell her on that day
because she always asked me like this
was the first time
you know it was a course of like
you're doing something i'm not doing
anything what are you doing like leave
me alone i'm not like i said why won't
you believe me but
it became to a point where we were on
the phone for so long and she wouldn't
let it go
a little bit it was like she wore me
down to the point of
you know like here
and let me tell you the shocking thing
about me telling her that revelation
i was like she was like i'm gone that's
it i'm out and i was like fine leave
great
thank you now we know
because i was still blaming her
i was like so you're not gonna stick
with me cool
you know what i'm terry crews i'm like
i'll get another one just like that
first of all hollywood does not care
if you lose your family in fact i'll get
three more movies they're like hey man
you have to go home just go right this
one set to the next
i said since when is hollywood cared if
you lost your family
since when has that been a career
breaker
never
in fact you get a divorce that's just
power for the course
and i was like cool
you can't handle it
you know and i had all kinds of excuses
where you know you don't understand my
upbringing i got high sex drive
um you know this thing you look at all
the women i could be having
none of that stuff worked man and all of
a sudden
and she left i remember hanging up the
phone and said don't come home i'm still
i'm not
and then there i was by myself i
remember in this hotel room
and i was with my little thing like
there it is it's over
and then a little voice was like
maybe it's me
i was like who is that you know i was
like no no first of all i just gave you
the rundown
on all the excuses on why it it
i had to do what i had to do because
that's what i needed
it's you terry
she's got nothing to do with this
and man
it was like cracking an egg and i was
trying to seal it
but the goop was going all over the
place and i'm like uh uh i'm trying to
put an egg back together
and i can't do it
i went damn it
it is me
it is me
like i lied
like
i was lying the whole time
and
what i presented to my wife
was an image
and she was married to that
but she wasn't married to the real terry
crews
she was married to the picture
she didn't know
and let me tell you man
one thing i learned which is so
important and incredible
after all this
and once me and my wife rebuilt our
marriage like we're literally from the
ground up
i learned
that intimacy
is the only thing i'm looking for and
when i say that
intimacy
really means
that someone knows you
all your stuff everything about you good
and bad
and loves you anyway
that's
all every man is looking for first of
all your mama does that
your mama knows everything
and she loves you anyway
that's why your love for your mother
will never dissipate a good mom
a good mom is always somebody that you
like
you put on a pedestal
why don't men
invite or allow that level of intimacy
well first of all
it's
it requires vulnerability
it requires you
you can't get intimacy without
vulnerability
it's impossible
because you're going to have to tell
your stuff
and imagine imagine the problem
because
if you can't tell
you'll never find intimacy
so
but that's the only thing you're looking
for
so what happens is you get sex sex and
love two different things
lots of sex
and it's always unfulfilling because
you're not
getting what you need you know what it's
like drinking salt water
you drink salt water
tastes good
feels like you're getting hydrated but
you're slowly but surely dehydrating
yourself
there's this almost apparent paradox
between when you're a man you think that
masculinity is the opposite of
vulnerability right
and you think masculinity is attractive
and also in your case
it can it can be our self-defense
through the hardest of times so the
thing that ends up being was our
self-defense and helped us to survive
ends up thing that being the thing that
stops us from being able to thrive right
in there
in their world and that like at some
point i see it on this this this podcast
the example i give is patrice evra who
was the famous manchester united
football player champion you know won
all the titles tough guy right grew up
on the streets of france where there was
gangs and he was sexually abused and he
was in a household where his brother had
an overdose and he was around that
environment and he built this like
tough exterior to help him get through
that yeah but then he gets into his
later life and has kids and he's cold
with his kids and he's cold with his
partner and then one day his wife's
nagging him and saying what's wrong with
you what's wrong with you want any
cracks
and at 40 odd years old or whatever
he was at the time he for the first time
ever tell someone he was sexually abused
by his headmaster and and about all that
pain that he had been you know
he'd held behind that shield of his
masculinity and until then he describes
the same thing until then he wasn't able
to have a real intimate relationship
with anybody
right and i think it's interesting
because so many men listening to this
you know and i was definitely one of
them um
um would have used masculinity or what
we think masculinity is as a way to
survive and to fit in and to get get
through and then it gets in our way yeah
later well i mean everything works until
it doesn't
drugs work until they don't
my pornography addiction worked until it
didn't did you tell her about that yes
i told her everything you know we had a
thing
and this is what was we required in
therapy was
the term is disclosure
and you have and you have to answer
every question she has
truthfully
and honestly
and i'ma tell you man it was like
shooting her
it was like shooting her
um
it was wild i remember in the nfl
that i look back on and i thought were
you know moments of
camaraderie but they were really it was
really disturbingly
twisted and that you know we would land
a plane you go to the strip club
and all the guys be you know you feel
like okay they're like i mean we're
going to the club we're going to magic
city atlanta we're doing it and
you're like okay are we going down there
and you go into the club and all of a
sudden there's girls out there and
they're doing their thing and then all
of a sudden one of the girls would come
off the stage
and then they'd want to talk to the
players
and it's like hey how are you doing you
know i got my kids and i'm doing it it's
like ah stop stop stop stop stop
you're ruining it
because she's talking kids she's talking
life she's talking stuff
the problem was she was becoming a human
being
before our eyes
just get back up on the stage
and be
a doll
be a picture
because pictures don't talk back
you know what i mean like you humans do
but you
be a mannequin
and you can we can manipulate you in any
way we want
but don't talk
because you're ruining it
and when i say
i've said this before and a lot of
people got on me but um
there was there's it was a thing where
we didn't really think
women were as human
as men were
that's that's a horrible
thought
but
it was everything that i was taught
um in my culture it was like hey man
when you got understand growing up in
flint in the hood the whole thing was
like hey man you better get your you
better tell your girl something better
get her in line
and you you were you owned your family
not like you served them you owned them
you owned your girl or girls
you know
the pimp mentality was praised
oh what's up pam oh that's my pimp right
there i mean these are father's kids
one of my best friends
you know his dad took him to a
prostitute
just to make sure he wasn't gay
huh
you're talking about
severely abusive behavior i don't even
you know this is another thing i even
bring it up in the book
you know
this was another thing even amongst the
women you know my mother
there was one time
my mother felt like she owned us
and i remember she made me she she
called me in the room and she said you
got hair down there
i was like what head down there she said
yeah
she said you have yes you have hair down
there
i said down where what are you talking
about there and she points at my
privates
i'm like yeah i guess and she said pull
it down let me see put your pants down
what
pull your pants down let me see
man
i'll never forget it
you know pull them down i'm looking out
the window
i'm just like trying to be somewhere
anywhere
other than here
but it was that extreme religious
controlled vibe where it was like
i control you
to the point where i can just make you
pull your pants down
inspect you
and listen
i don't think it was it wasn't sexual in
nature
but it was definitely abusive in nature
and it was to let me know
that i run this
and i remember pulling my pants up
and trying to forget it for years
for years
and i confronted my mother about it
i remember when i was grown
and again already successful but i had
already went through d-day with my wife
and going through therapy
and i called my mother i said do you
remember when you
when you made me do that she said do
what
i said ma
remember
she said i didn't do that
i said mom
you did that
and she denied it
and then my sister came in and was like
why are you trying to break up the
family are you trying to do all this
stuff in it i was like
i didn't make this up
and she said well if it if it did happen
i was young and stupid and you know and
she just tried to excuse it and this
thing because it's too painful
it's too painful
no one wants to know they hurt their
kids
but it happened
and
it was part of me getting through every
little bit and see i called the book
tough
because
remember i brought up the fact that
you know
the courage to control the things you
can
you can there's a lot you can control
about yourself
see
i was
hope like literally helpless
to do like whichever way the wind blew
terry crews was going
what else can i do this is another thing
where
you could bait me into anything
i could you know another thing here in
my culture it was that
you know if somebody called you [ __ ]
you knock them out
no matter what no questions asked
don't even hesitate
you supposed to and they would tell you
hey man you anybody call you [ __ ] knock
them out
well the thing is though
is that
usually when you do that you go to jail
you can't prove somebody calls you a
[ __ ]
unless it's recorded and then it's like
your word against but somebody's laying
on the ground you just assaulted
somebody
it's no different than if you go to a
football game and somebody does a cheap
shot and you hit them back who gets
ejected
the jail is full
of black men who were baited
by a word
and had to have to follow the rules we
got to follow the rules right so anybody
call you [ __ ] you get knocked out
but here's the point and here's the
thing that changed for me and this is
where i learned
what i could control
there are no [ __ ]
no such thing
you might as well call somebody a
leprechaun
there's no such thing as a [ __ ]
and i said holy cow
i can get mad about someone calling me
something i'm not
like
the thing i like to say is bill gates
if you call him broke
he just look at you and go
go in his helicopter and fly away you
know what i mean
he wouldn't even be threatened by that
but here's the thing
if you really do think you're a [ __ ]
that's when it affects you
that's when you want to fight
and i said but i'm not a [ __ ]
and i realized that
there was so much i could let wash off
because i examined it and i and i put it
to the test
but you got to be tough to do that
when you look back on that period what
was your lowest moment
i would have to say that the day i went
to
[Music]
that massage problem
it was law
i wrote i write about in the book i just
think
it's just and i describe it in detail
just because i never
thought i would do something like that
on my wife like
how did i end up here you know you just
look around like what in the world
you know it's like um
it's almost like having a faulty
instrument panel and you're trying to
get to
seattle and you end up in mexico you're
like what in the world
how did i do this
it was low like i that was the real
moment i actually considered suicide
like for a minute
i remember thinking
what if i just found a way to die
and then
make it look like it was an accident you
know like i was kind of thinking of
things you know after the massage parlor
yeah or the ten years ten years later
when you start speaking no no that was
after i mean that 2000 was a dark time
that's why i was like
to me
d-day 10 years later
was actually an awakening
because it all happened in one day it
was like
denial and then all of a sudden
acceptance
that i got it screwed up
um
i don't i don't look at d-day as a low
day at all i look at it as the day i
woke up the day of like wow
i was forced
to see myself as i really was because i
i had a great image of myself and it was
like oh i'm this i'm and i'm not that
bad because i'm in comparison to
everyone else i'm great
but
it didn't it did not pass muster because
she
had to be the one to dictate that
one of the other symptoms of being tough
is introduced in the prologue section of
the book where you talk about
the day where you get in an altercation
and there's extreme violence i mean
violence shows up there but but you also
see it throughout your story and the
other key moment that really stayed in
my mind and it was a very graphic scene
is when i believe you're on the way to
dinner with your wife and you get a
phone call saying that big terry your
father
has
punched your mother again
and her tooth is turned in her mouth
tell me about that phone call
man
first of all i i made my father vow
i said man look i'm bringing my kids
this is the first time i'd actually been
in hollywood this is post nfl i have
already had a job but my first job was a
tv show called battle dome where i
basically beat people up uh it was like
american gladiators on steroids um
they put me in a cage set the ends on
fire and i would take three contestants
and pummel them it was i mean hey look i
know about violence okay and i could do
it um
and so i came back home for christmas
and we call it the christmas from hell
and so we were there and
we're going out to dinner with some
friends and detroit is about 45 minutes
from flint and we were driving to
detroit with me and my wife to go see
our friends and we get a call we're
literally 10 minutes into the ride
and i get a call from my aunt she's like
oh my god you know your father hit your
mother
and i'm like what
he was drinking
somehow the holidays
brings out the alcohol you know
everybody wants to drink on alcohol it's
really activating
triggering for alcoholics
and i said did my kids see it she said
yes terry
they saw it they were real kids my kids
were there how old were you oh i was uh
i just started so i was about 31 32
years old
and um
yeah man
it was
i couldn't believe it because i told him
i said man my kids have never came up in
this they've never seen this
you know and
and i have three daughters at the time
not five now
but i couldn't believe and they were
they were just shocked they had never
been in that and all i remember is just
the
the the feeling of surreal terror
you know what i mean like this big man
is beating my mother up what do i do i
don't know you know
and then they were in there like
why is he doing this like they never
seen it
and i said damn it
man i turned that i did a u-turn i said
listen
take the kids take them over your house
make sure it's just me and victoria in
that house
understand make sure of it
she got the kids out whole thing
dude
i roll up in that house i say hey man
didn't i tell you
he said oh man shut up man get out my
face
pow
hit him dead in his mouth
and there it was i was like man
all those times you beat my mother up
all those times i was running around
five years old scared couldn't do
nothing froze up i'm bigger than your
ass now huh
how you like that pow pow
he's screaming at me to stop he's
bleeding
he's screaming and i'm just wailing on a
man and i'm like no how you like that
how this is how she felt and you're
crying while you're doing this i beat
his ass
and i'm in tears
but listen to me man
it was nothing it was empty
like
nothing i i thought
there it is i got revenge
revenge is complete
and it was hollow
it was like an empty box
it's like a big box with a giant bow on
it
what now
i was like you just beat up your dad
big deal
it didn't settle the score didn't change
him
didn't fix my mother's tooth
didn't do anything my mother moved right
back in
i was like what the
hell and so
i didn't come back home for 10 years
after that
i was tired
i i remember just being shot like
this this was supposed to be so good
this was supposed to be so sweet
it was nothing
it didn't work
and
you know one thing i discovered even in
writing this book
was that
you can either have success or revenge
but you can't have both
it's
success would have been
transcending that moment
taking your mother out of there
and just leaving him onto his own
devices
because that's a punishment you
let these people do
you know these kind of people
that stuff doesn't work
because it just makes them more angry
you know me makes the whole world blind
doesn't it it makes the whole world
blind
but
success is when you leave but revenge is
quick
i'm gonna have to say this because
there was a time
when i was will smith
when you could say something i would
have walked up on that stage and smacked
you
but when i learned how to be chris rod
when i learned how to keep control
and actually
not let things descend
into chaos
because that's what that could have been
when you look at chris and
if he'd imagine if he'd have fought back
there would have been no recovering
that would have been the end of the
academy awards i already was by the way
but
it would have been
complete bedlam
quick one as you might know crafted are
one of the sponsors of this podcast and
crafted are a jewelry brand and they
make really meaningful pieces of
jewellery and this piece by crafted when
i put it on for me it represents courage
it represents ambition it represents
being calm and loving and respectful and
nurturing while also being the
antithesis of that seemingly the
antithesis of that which is um sometimes
a little bit aggressive with my goals
and determined and courageous and brave
the really wonderful thing about crafted
jewelry is it's super affordable it
looks amazing the pieces hold tremendous
meaning and they are really well made
what was the process for you to become
that man to take on your ego and i
remember reading about the moment when
you're on holiday and your daughter
spills her drink and yeah and you would
have reacted it was actually my son it
was my son yeah spills his drink and you
would have normally reacted with anger
or being mad at that moment but your
your wife actually noticed that you
didn't and she said to you you've
actually changed that was the moment
wait first of all what was it that
changed you what was the process you
know
remember this was years in
okay and it was small minor minor
changes just one after the other one
after the other
it was a process of constantly examining
you got understand like there was a
moment where i would walk outside and it
would look different like oh like the
sun would look different and it was
weird i'll never forget um coming out of
therapy
and this guy was like
they were like terry you have to learn
how to tell people no because i was a
pleaser
and so i remember being at dinner and
people were like can i get autographs
i'm like yeah and i would sign
autographs for an hour with my family
there and my my wife was like terry
we're here
we can't even enjoy it i said yeah but
these are my fans these are the people
that pay our bills and then
she's like you got you can't tell them
no
just for an hour
and i couldn't
because i was like i got to play and
there's i remember being in counseling
and
the counselor asked me she said
what if a director told you to do
something you didn't want to do i said
well i have to do it and she said no you
don't
i said yes i do
she said no you don't terry i said well
i'm an actor
he said yeah but you don't have to do
what the direct everything the director
tells you to do i said yes i do because
i'm an actor and she's like no
no you don't
she said terry
you don't have to do that i said but i
would lose my job
and she said well get another job
i said but i'm an actor
and she said terry
you don't have to do
what you don't want to do
i didn't know
especially since i was such a pleaser it
was one of them things well yeah yeah
and i'll never forget this guy came up
to me saying man can i get an autograph
and i was gonna do it i was in practice
i said
and i looked at him i said no
he said come on man come on man i said
no
no no and i went crazy the guy was like
dude relax man
and i was like shaking
it was the first time
i was exercising this no my no no
and i was shaking i got back in the car
and i said you guys i was going i
thought i was going crazy
i thought i was going crazy
but what i was doing
was dissecting
and piecing and understanding who i was
and what made me tick
and it's so thorough and it got so
thorough to the point where i was like
oh that
why do i feel angry
if someone says that
or why am i why am i insulted why
is it me or is it them
and see and once i started asking these
questions i could let it go
and i was like oh man that's got nothing
to do with me
but whereas before it was just you
insulted me and dude
the process of doing this kept going on
and on and on and on and on and on
to the point where when my son spilled
that water
i knew he was innocent
whereas before he would be guilty
whereas before
man watch where you're going you got to
pay attention
if you don't pay attention now then you
spilled this water all over the place
and then you know how much this cost
then i would have went all you know how
many i can't count to you how many
family gatherings are ruined
how many you know theme park outings
i've crushed
people in tears i'm going back to the
room
because i just everything had to be
perfect
everything had to be the way it's
supposed to be and then
you didn't do it the way i wanted it was
it was hot my way or the highway
but dude that moment he spilled that
water and i was like oh man it's okay
it's all right dude everybody on that
table was like
are you serious
and my wife looked at me
she looked at me
she said i was different
and i knew i was
after all we've been through
i'll never forget she said terry you're
different
terry i'm with you
she said i love you
i said oh god i stuck with you
because you were willing to do the work
and it was uh
that's what i knew
that's what i knew
and that's one of the biggest reasons
why i have to tell it
simply because
i don't want people to feel like they're
alone
i don't want men to feel like they're
alone i want men to feel like
it's just them
and they don't know any way out in the
whole thing i said
i have to be vulnerable i have to share
this part so that you know how far i
came
you know this i have no interest in
showing that image anymore
i have no idea like i said i
i told you earlier i've moved from
fiction to non-fiction
why did that mean so much to you when
she said that
wow
because i knew i wanted to make it right
it's not enough
to say you're sorry
it's just not enough
it's like
it's not enough to hit people in your
car
and go my bad
and pull off
but you have to understand in the world
today
you said my bad i said i'm sorry
bye
and you leave people broken
you just hit somebody with your car
and you pull off and go like my bad yell
it out
it's not enough
not enough
i damaged
my family i damaged my wife
and that's when i knew when the person i
hit
can come back
and tell me they love me and they hug me
and they know
that i was truly sorry
that's the forgiveness i always wanted
that's what i wanted
and you have to make amends
you have to do what's within your power
to make things right
and
again a lot has been said for
just yeah i said i'm sorry and the whole
thing but man it's just never enough
you have to do the work and and you have
to pay the price like you have to stay
by the stay by whoever you hit you got
to wait till the ambulance comes you got
to wait till the police comes you got to
fill out the police report
you got to own up to it
and that's what i did
what do you think your life would be
like if you hadn't looked yourself in
the mirror and started to own up to
and confront that
i i don't believe i'd be here today
i really don't
um
my temper
i would have went off on somebody
um
i don't i don't i honestly can't say i
know i wouldn't be married
i probably
you know the division is
you know hollywood and
relationship to relationship
just trying to find
somebody that would stick with me long
enough
for the pictures
um
not love man
you know
this whole thing
it's wild because
unless somebody knows who you are
and
and really really is willing to love you
um
you know
hollywood doesn't do that
he doesn't operate like that in fact
what's so crazy about hollywood is that
they'll make movies about love like
there's the main star will be like
the star will be talking about oh my god
you know there'll be like this great
movie that was all about this lovely
relationship and he's a rapist
that's this town
you know what i mean
and
it's wild
but it's real
uh
i mean
they don't make no it's the same thing
that happened to me when uh my own agent
assaulted me
and i went to the head of the motion
picture department
and i was like hey man
i said this dude you can't molest the
clients
and the guy looked at me and said he's a
partner
yeah yeah he can
your agent at a party well documented
yes came up to you and started great
grabbed my
private she grabbed my
dick basically and i'm like yo
i look i don't know what he was on
because he wasn't drunk
but he was on something okay i don't
know what it was i have no idea but he
was not
acting himself he was licking his tongue
out and acting all funny and weird it's
like he was tweaking this nervous weird
energy like somebody had a molly or
something crazy he was not there okay
and i was just like man he was looking
at me like oh my god i don't know what
was and his wife was there and my wife
was there and
again it was really weird because here
we are and this really
you know hollywood party
hot famous people everywhere
and here he's listen he's the lones
agent he's eddie murphy's agent he's
adam sandler's agent he's the head of
the motion picture department at william
morris endeavor and he lost his mind and
look i pushed him off he comes back
again i push him off again i'm like yo
man [ __ ] off me man
and
he starts laughing ah
and i'm going what
now i'm feeling so
crazy now
i'm about to put my hand through his
head
and my wife
i looked at her
and she's and this is where i went to
because my wife has seen me there's a
long trail of people who've been knocked
out by terry crews okay
so she looked at me but there was a time
a long time ago she made me promise
that i would not be violent
anymore and i was part of the therapy it
was part of what we're doing
and i realized
this was another trial
this was no different than being called
[ __ ]
this was no different
than a pull and a bait
that if i went for it
and what's so crazy is i asked people
the question like
if i had knocked him out because a lot
of people said you should have just done
it man what's wrong with you man you're
weak
but i go
would you believe me
no
no
you even you the people who say
that i should have done it
would you have believed the story
that this guy grabbed my balls
and i just whale and i wailed off on him
and he happens to be the head of the
motion picture department why would he
do that
terry crews big
superstar
probably got drunk
probably knocked him out because he got
angry
hey man nobody would believe that
but you believe me now
[Music]
because i didn't do it
when people take that you took that to
your agency the head of your agency and
you told him what what had happened and
he said
he said
well
he's a partner
and he said listen this is what i'm
gonna do terry
he said i'm gonna take his title
and he's going to be
suspended for 30 days and i went
huh
so you're going to send him on vacation
was he giving you that fake energy you
know when they're fake handling it was
this fake
it was like dealing with the devil
and he first of all when i met with him
he was like i'm going to give you a
meeting as if
the he was going to grace he was going
to let me grace his presence
because you know he owns all these
people in hollywood
and i'm like
what the hell
when people talk about why they didn't
come forward they often mention an
element of fear
yes for what that powerful individual
might do to their career or their life
or what happened even right after it
happened he told me the other day did
adam bennett called me he was like i'm
sorry i was broke and you know what
i said hey man
you got to be held responsible for what
you just did i don't know what's up so
what's up and so everybody told me we're
taking this very seriously and we're
going to be we're going to get back to
you with some with what's going to
happen nothing happened right so a year
later
when the metoo thing happens
i snapped
because i knew nothing was going down
they let them get away with it
and so
when i when i met with ari
i said hey ari
i said man
first of all you wrote a letter to mel
gibson
demanding that he be kicked out of
hollywood for anti-semitic remarks you
wrote a letter to the huffington post
you can google it right now and it tells
how he needs to be kicked out i said
look anti-semitic remarks as
reprehensible as they are are not
illegal
i said
but
sexual assault is
i said you i don't you're talking about
a a
a
30-day suspension i said man you can't
molest the clients and come back to work
ever
i said if somebody in the mail room did
this they'd be out how much more
the head of the agency a partner
i said what are you saying he said
it's different
and you know what it reminded me of
it reminded me of the standing
happened to will smith
it's different
it's well smiled
chris rock standing over there nobody
goes to him
he's standing all by himself
but who's bigger
who's got the best light
ah we love well
it's different
and i said dude
no it's not
no
and i said all right man i said you
really want this
and he said hey man it is what it is
i said okay
i see you when i see you
and what happened was i decided to sue
i spent 500 000
of my own money
suing william morris endeavor
and what was crazy is that they bought
me every step of the way
until
people came out of the woodwork
people like terry
he did this to me too
let me join your case
i was like
because remember you don't rob the
biggest
you know bank on the in the city you
start out with the branches you start
out smaller
and all these people started to come out
of the woodwork
about what this man had done
and then all of a sudden they were white
flag
our bad
and he decided to do
we they decided to retire him
so he basically retired
you're not allowed to say fire but he
was retired and i was like good
and i didn't want any money i never
wanted money in the first place because
their whole thing was they were scared
of while you were what how much do you
want
i don't want to die
i said dude i would spend a million
dollars to win one dollar
so what do you want to do
and so what they did i got my my
attorney fees back
he was gone
and but that's all they should have done
in the first place
because it's unacceptable remember it's
not enough to say my bad
you can't tell me you can't
grab me in front of my wife and all this
and be like oh my bad i got high that
day
that's not enough does will smith remind
you of who you used to be in that moment
because this is why listen i love will
and i love chris
you know i love will
and all i could think about was like oh
my god that's me
that was me
and does that give you empathy for yes
yes
yes i hope that's what everybody's
getting from this interview because i
had nothing but empathy
for will at that time
because i'm going no no he got pulled in
he got baited you know a joke
now again it wasn't funny
it's not even one of chris's best jokes
it wasn't even
and i looked at that thing and i went oh
no
well no
and and it didn't hit me until he was
back in his chair
and you saw he lost it
and he was saying these things and i
said oh no
because it reminded me of
it just reminded me i would have done
that man
i would have done worse than that
i'll be honest
what will what will did was nice
compared to the stuff i did
one of the things that you say in your
book
in section 2 which is titled shame is
that your overachieving came from
insecurity which is the
other side
the other
consequence of the context in which you
were raised right the other the other
side of it so you've got the one side
which created anger and all of these
other things and these the escape of
pornography but the other side of it the
thing that everybody claps for which
made you an anomaly as well and gave you
that drive and that hard work was
was
your success and that came from the same
place and that's sometimes funny when
you think
the thing my light side and my dark side
originated from the same catalyst yes
right yes it and it's um
it it's it's kind of wild because
these things you know if you get a lot
done
when you are
running off
shame or even even revenge these kind of
things you get a lot done like this
energizes like
okay i gotta prove
that i'm this i gotta prove it and again
it's it's typically
i would i you know i've seen women do it
too but i would say for men it's a
typical move where we feel bad
but then you have to find a way to feel
good about yourself
you know what i mean and you have to
find something to feel good about so you
immerse yourself in work you know is
that what you did i did oh definitely
were you like a
obsessed or a worker
oh my god i mean hey man you talking
about i used to
i'm the kind of guy who
would
work out until you passed out like like
work out to
every muscle in my body cramped up
because i'm trying to figure out you
know you came you're an nfl player it
didn't go great for you there right and
then you arrive in la
and without acting
training like extensive acting training
without coming from hollywood in your
30s you managed to build this career and
become a really successful actor you
spend the first two years in la
you know pretty pretty broke
working
jobs people want to work but then you
rise from that point to become this
tremendously successful actor in a
completely different field at a time in
life where people would consider pretty
late to get into acting in your 30s
and i'm looking at that thinking what
was it about terry that made him
successful
in that discipline when that where
that's not where he came from he came
from the nfl he came from art school
right but i have to say
um
it was the only thing i could feel good
about myself for
you know what i mean like
it was one of those things where all my
self-worth
came from it
that's why when she said you know what
what if a director did something you
didn't want you to do i said i have to
do it
because
everything i was wrapped up in
their opinion of me
you see what i mean so you go farther
than that you do that you you it was
people going around block once i go
around the block four times
so i remember even being on security
you know we would stand for 12 hours
straight you know
and so i remember just being
this person who
you know they were like
we can break you for lunch but i would
bring my own lunch and have a stand
right there right next to me and i would
jog in place you're a joke in place oh
yeah oh yeah i mean i was gonna get the
workout in
and
i said i'm never gonna let my body get
down i'm gonna because see remember
like mom i'm gonna be the best kid
i'm gonna be the best
kid in the church that you've ever seen
because of
the pleaser thing and the whole thing
and then the shame would make you bad
again
and always knowing and feeling in your
heart that at your core
you're bad
so you must never get there
in fact do so much you never be alone
you know i mean
do so much
that you don't have to face yourself
because then things start to fall out
then things start to fall apart so
dude you know i had i had like three
jobs at the same time there were times i
was like i would sleep in four hours and
i would get up and
do the security job then i'll go to my
bouncing gig
and i would do two or three i would try
to get another gig on the other side and
then even as an actor it was it was
actually illegal i was doing three
movies at the same time one time you
can't do that but i didn't tell anybody
but i was that focused i was like man
i'm here i'm here
and i can show them i can be
i can be beyond
and see for me
it was like
you know you have to understand the nfl
you know for me it was now about
catching ability throwing ability it was
my ability to take tremendous amounts of
pain
that was my skill in the nfl i could
take a lot of pain
i could endure a lot and so i was like
i'm going to i'm just going to be
unstoppable when you start doing the
work with the therapist and you start
unpacking a lot of this stuff how does
this change your relationship with work
oh
it became where
hey man
you're good
because you're
because you're you
and then the default because this is
another thing i had to and one thing
that our therapist would really
highlight for me
was
have you ever seen a
a child is not bad
and
it hit me
that if that was our state then children
would be evil you know all children
would be evil but no no all children are
good
and it's programmable
and so what i did i put a picture of
myself
on my
desktop
in my computer and then i had even
printed it out put it in a little frame
and it was me
at six years old like my little two
teeth missing
and i was like that's you man
i get i get choked up looking at it
because it's like even i think about it
i'm like that's still you
hello good little boy
what would you tell him
if he was sitting right next to you
if he was sitting right next to you what
would you tell him
you would hug him
you know
the little boy who kissed his dad and
got shunned out the room
you would be like man it's okay
i love you man
you're a good boy
you know
i'm the same person i'm still him
i'm still him
i got in touch with that dude
and i said that's who i am
and that got rid of the shame now guilt
is good guilt says you did something
wrong and you need to fix it
but you need the shame ain't working
you ain't got nothing to be shamed about
nothing
you know it's funny because that people
make i remember being in high school
and you do something dumb and fart by
mistake oh and they're like ah
i don't fart i know people literally say
that man i never farted ever and you're
like oh man you don't fire oh man am i
the only one
i started to realize man that shame
stuff it's manipulative it's people use
that stuff
i never did that
and now all they're doing is trying to
one-up you
and i realized man just be you you know
what
one thing i that that changed for me
is i stopped competing with people
and i
said
don't try to be the best
be the only
be the only
there's only one terry crews if you want
terry crews you got you got to get terry
crew
you know you see in scripts they're like
terry crews type
you know i i don't know i love everybody
i love to rock i love kevin hart i love
all these other guys
but i'm terry crews
you never be like me
and i'll never be like them
i'm the only
and by being the only you are the best
that's it and i went oh my god
like that was watershed
so much pressure off
you see what i'm saying it's like whoa
now i'm working because i like it
i'm not working because i gotta prove it
and keep up with all of this he's got
two houses i need three
because this is another thing i started
to ask myself what am i missing am i
missing anything i'm not if i got one
house am i missing something
no
if i have one wife that loves me
am i missing something because i don't
have 10 girlfriends
i'm telling you it's it's powerful
terry thank you thank you um
a very necessary book in our time that's
the best way i can describe it because
and i feel privileged to have had the
joy to read it before it's come out but
a very necessary book for all the
reasons that i'm sure are evident for
everyone listening today but you know
there's a lot of men and women because
this is you know it takes two to tango
but it also takes two to understand um
there's a lot of men and women suffering
from the consequences of the things that
cause the insidious toxic
corruptive behavior you see in people in
men today and your book is tackles that
head-on in the most vulnerable honest
important way and the only way to be
honest you are a man that represents
for many especially in movies
being strong and what you do in this
book is you redefine what being strong
means
and that's certainly something that i
took away from it and will have a big
impact on my life going forward so thank
you so much for your time and everything
and writing such an important book i
think it's going to be an absolute
tremendous hurt especially for the
people that listen to this and
we do have a closing tradition on this
podcast which is the last guest
writes a question for the next guest
so in a weird way they all have a
conversation with each other okay and i
don't get to read it until open source
what is your mood
right now
my mood right now
is
satiated that's the only way i can
describe it it feels
feels good
it's just
get it out talk about your life
the way you want
to talk about it you know what's i think
social media
pulls everything out of context
and so compu
you mean something and someone can say
it means another thing but this
is it's a very
satisfying and satiating feeling to be
able to talk
and tell your story and not have it be
taken out of context so beautiful
that's my mood right now
terry thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]